foreign
good afternoon gentlemen yeah you bet
what's happening
first-hand caller long time oh I love
this one yeah well well on my way to
debt-free uh living uh only because
listening to you guys over the years I
appreciate it so much
um so my question is um back in my
stupid Finance times like 2005 2007 I
made some really dumb business decisions
I feel
um I have one outstanding debt uh from a
company I probably shouldn't mention
um but uh so there was like a 37 000
debt balance that I that I was kind of
Wheeling with him about three years ago
uh about a year and a half ago I was
working with a company I was trying to
settle
um I was trying to pitch him like I
don't know like 18 Grand to settle on to
37 000 they denied it said and we kind
of lost contact about a year and a half
ago uh recently received a letter from
them they're willing to settle this
whole thing for like five grand this is
a business line of credit
um I am the owner of the company
so I'm just I need some advice as to uh
if you were me would you follow through
and pay that five grand or just tell
them to go jump on a lake well did you
take out the amount of debt the 37. it's
it's certainly my debt yes but yeah as I
said they hadn't contacted me they kind
of you know lost lost communication with
them uh wouldn't do the 18 now coming
back for five I guess I just need some
advice which direction to go I would be
grateful it's at five and I would stop
losing sleep over it and pay them the
five and uh move on with my life but I
would not just ignore this and tell them
to kick rocks and pound sand I mean you
took out the debt you signed your name
on the paper yeah I think you do the
thing you know have the Integrity to
just go all right it was a long time ago
I could probably ignore it and have it
go away but man I'm gonna sleep better
at night now when I did the right thing
so you're so close man
yeah and there's nothing on my credit
report regarding this nothing the event
they haven't sent you know they haven't
sent me in or anything like that oh good
and that's why I'm like you know where
I'm at right now I'm I'm more than
willing to get responsibility for it I
just said like I said I just have never
been in this situation and uh Wanda yeah
be sure to get it in writing that this
thing is clear yeah yep
that you have no more relationship with
them that's the way to do it yeah and
there's this uh
you know I love that he's asking the
question I love that he's willing to be
transparent to go okay do I do this or
do I just say forget it man it's not on
my record statute of limitations and
he's making a and and you know there's
just something that uh it does for your
soul to settle this thing oh absolutely
yeah on one side there's the integrity
and character of you know cool I took
out the debt on the other side it really
does free you and you don't realize the
weight that these situations have in our
minds on us physically I mean it's it's
absolutely incredible once you really
look at it so it really is I'm doing it
Ken getting rid of the day